is Chauncey Billups here on the
Richardson show how you doing Chauncey
what was going on you tell Dora I'm fine
first things first this Paul Pierce have
something against LeBron John see what
he got for me here on that one it's so
funny because everybody asks me the same
thing like was so appalling LeBron well
I mean you know I he's never said them
to me but obviously they had a lot of
you know tough battles and dogfights and
I used to conference you know maybe but
I'm not sure though do you think that
Joe that LeBron is number two in the
category of best player on planet Earth
behind Kevin Durant I do not I do not I
think LeBron is still the best player in
the game I think JT is the best clout on
perhaps the best team and he's the best
scorer in our league but no I think the
bronze the best all-around player leads
to so what happened in Game four to make
things radically different from the
first throat what the Cavs picked up the
tempo something that they thought they
know the rest of the world thought would
be crazier than even try but they play
fast the biggest difference is they the
three-ball you know they were the best
3-point shooting team in the league this
year and finally they got that
three-ball gone they were able to you
know break down a defense and for the
kick outs and they knocked down a record
number three point shots but not only
that they played they made the game ugly
you know they died for those Falls they
made it they made it chippy and that's
the way that you have to play if you
don't have a chance to beat a lawyer so
is that sustainable I don't know I don't
know what I hit twenty four threes again
tonight no I doubt it's only that's a
reason why I am da record it's only
happen at one time but they are the best
they are the best three-point soon were
at least the best de pointes
entertainment league they don't need at
least 16 17 threes which they can do but
this this goes they team is just
different you know and Kevin Durant you
know that they're just it's different
this year so let's let's let's I guess
pull the hood back on this for a second
and Chauncey Billups is this the best
way then to beat the Warriors is to is
to out pace them out
tempo them what do you think oh I don't
know that you can out pace or tempo them
but um you know again like I said they
you know LeBron things
best player in basketball so you know
they had the best player in the series
and LeBron James and if he can knock
down jump shots he's just a different
cover I mean there's nothing that you
can really do with him Kyrie he's got
gone he's after 39 of the last two games
hopefully his game travels on the road
but he's shown that they can't really
control him so those two guys are
playing great and they're getting
three-point shooting from all the other
pieces is this this will be going six
well what are you thinking do you think
that actually happens tonight
Johnson um you know I do I do actually
you know I think they come in with a ton
of confidence I think pressures on the
lawyers to close them out oh the press
is not really on the Cavs I mean they
play on house money at this point nobody
thinks they can win it was down Oh three
has never been done in the history of
the game so I think the press is on the
Warriors tonight you know to close it
out but I think the confidence you know
isn't is in a cache court well if that
happens tonight Chauncey if you guys are
taking a flight to Cleveland for Game
six that would I mean that would
certainly ratchet the pressure up so
you're thinking third quarter fourth
quarter if this is still a game that the
Warriors begin to feel that on their
shoulders God is this guy if it's a six
point game in the fourth quarter you
know six seven minutes left in the game
the pressure will be so by words but I
will say in fairness to the Warriors I
mean they got two guys in a starting
lineup that warrant that wasn't a part
of that last year what Katie Ann's I
even those odds I probably won't be in a
game in the fourth quarter um eg
probably will and that happened to him
you know but they're this there's
something to be said about you know a
team coming back 3-1 on you've been
winning two games of three and you're
building we'll see but I tell you Steph
Curry has been a different player this
year too so it's it's an uphill climb
for the photo for the Cavs absolutely
but I'm looking forward to seeing it
well I mean you could say that it did
actually happen to Durant
you're just not in a warrior's uniform
it was against the Warriors you know or
the Sun be informing me there's a bear
up 3-1 and that one too you need yeah he
was on a business sense very true you
know I'm just throwing that stuff out so
you used that tonight you know with a
Jalen beetle for the priesthood chili
and the man who's got the hater-aide out
for for LBJ employees yeah you know you
know and I talked about this with Jack
the other day Chauncey is just what what
is going to be the one this is all done
every leagues a copycat league but every
league is also trying to take down a
team that that's one at all what is the
reaction to let's say the Warriors do
take this thing down what is the
reaction everybody tries to form their
own super teams or or we go back to the
days of your coach from the big three
Oakley were where where it's going to be
all hands literally figuratively on deck
start putting finesse teams on their ass
underneath the pink there I mean I would
like to I would like the ladder you know
it's almost like you got to have you
gotta have like four all-stars now to
compete with to compete with the
Warriors not just three I mean four but
and that's crazy and you know the parody
of the league is really down right now
obviously so I'm just hoping that you
know I don't like what the big is that
you know the super team thing you know I
really don't like our like parity I like
competition you know I like the
competitive fabric that I was new in the
league so we'll see I mean we'll see how
it kind of shapes up so when it all
comes down to it do you think the
Celtics should in that regard try and
build with the youth and with the same
guys that they have or flip the number
one overall pick for free and
established big time all-star should
that happen that's tough I mean it if
you looking at the league and you saying
you want to wait out these next four
years while katie is you know and these
guys are on their run then you start
then you build with the youth but if you
want to try to go after those guys right
now then obviously you don't have to add
some
severe Moe Chauncey Billups of ESPN here
a few more minutes with him from Oakland
do you see the again you're on the
killer threes in cubes big three League
I got cube coming with a me Trask on
Friday and studio here to talk about it
Niagara Michael Rapaport sit in the
chair for me on Friday did you see that
this is going to be an Olympic sport
three on three now John did I did i'm
i've been known about the for the while
that they was going to be on the docket
i'm on the board of USA basketball so I
knew this for a while and been three
basketball is used around the world it's
never been here in our country but
around the world it's you know it's a
big deal um so I was happy to hear you
know there's gonna be a three on three
yeah there'll be a metal sport so are
you gonna are you gonna play in it would
you do it no I doubt it man about it but
oh now I'm excited
so I'm - I'm too old for that man what
do you mean you too old for that
come on pillow for that now forty years
old there hmm
so I don't know I mean to me youth
begins at 40 Chauncey I mean you're at
one mr. bigshot on Twitter why not yes
yeah yes I put you know I'm not in I'm
not allowed me to be completing these 22
23 24 year old boos where I got a good
one Mike Chauncey how about this one
because since you're on USA Basketball
how about levar ball suits up for three
on three because he could he could take
Jordan someone I take had to take on the
rest of the world what do you think I
couldn't make Monty is Nick month am I
saying I've seen some highlights over
but now you couldn't make my squad
mm-hmm
who would make your team well I would
need some young and lytic athletic guys
that kind of know how to play the game
three on three is so much about you know
having a good IQ if you if you run plays
properly you know I mean you should
always get open shot know so it's more
about knowing how to play and then if
you got athletes to like and that you
know that you can they can't match up
with then you should have an advantage
so do you think that you your Pistons
team that you are on with
Wallace could beat these warriors as
she'd has publicly stated Chauncey I say
this it depends on the rules if the
rules are right now where you can't
really compete and touch a guy I mean
our regular files will be flagging ones
a Tuesday right now so if it's 2004
rules absolutely if it's right now rules
we're gonna have a tough tough time
because we probably all gonna be found
out but third quarter starts well you're
on T USA basketball and I know that
again that that doesn't govern the NBA
but do you think the rules should be
changed that there should be some form
of a throwback that allows the sort of
handshakes with you I'll be honest which
I play yours Invesco a lot and playing
over there the game is so much more
physical I mean it's so much more
physical and I love it I love it but
it's funny like you watch some of our
teams play over there and there there's
some guys that games just don't
translate because of the physicality and
which that they play with over there so
it's a different game I don't want to
adopt all the rules but just from a
physicality standpoint I think it'll be
great Farley all right you how you
enjoying the the paparazzi Chauncey you
enjoy doing that I have a bee in your
ear or do you want to go into a front
office what do you got for me uh I don't
know man we'll see it could be both at
some point that was always a you know a
desire mine at some point we'll see what
happens but I've enjoyed love I love my
job that's great okay well enjoy
chanting when you're in Los Angeles come
on and visit me in studio I'd love to
chat with you then in person also will
effects where you got it at Chauncey
Billups the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can crawl us from the app you
can email us from the app just download
it trust me you'll enjoy